that Washington Post piece that we just
showed you the Tweet about
uh it was a 5 000 word diatribe it was
completely and utterly ridiculous uh
Kaylee mcenany you know Kaylee used to
work for Donald Trump now Donald Trump
hates her uh she read the entire piece
and she uh summed it up quite eloquently
here on Fox
and what they are doing to the first
lady of Florida it is uh she's
Unstoppable she's smart she's strong
she's accomplished and she's
conservative so she will be attacked I
read every word of this hit piece last
night it was in The Washington Post it
was north of 5 000 words uh and the
animating themes were this okay they
love being around each other Rhonda
Santos and Casey DeSantis they're
private and when he was in Congress he
would leave at if the vote was at noon
he'd be on his way to the airport at
1206 because he wanted to see his family
sounds like a great marriage to me and
then the other complaint about Rhonda
Santos was this there were three things
he liked to talk about with his staff
the Constitution baseball and golf I
mean okay why is this bad so my take
away from this is this is the most
flattering hit piece I have ever read
and is it this is the worst thing they
have on the desantises wow what a great
family uh a role model family Trump is
going to be doubly unhappy with her
today uh but look we've seen this thing
right this is rinse and repeat this is
them lying about Trump all the time and
now they're just moving over to the AI
that they know is the real threat again
Casey DeSantis is a seriously like
lovely decent person I saw them like
playing with the kids and making sure
that her son had the chicken fingers and
then they got ice cream and and Ron went
out of it the governor went out of his
way to give some food off his plate the
kid like it's just it's just so
profoundly ridiculous but the corporate
press the mainstream media they cannot
stop
oh
[Music]